du betrittst eine andere welt eine welt
des luxus und genuss durch einen tunnel
aus licht wird durch ein wunderschönes
restaurant geführt und ist 15 gänge im
teuersten restaurant deine stadt leute
was ist das für ein leben jetzt gehört
15 gänge im teuersten restaurant der
stadt so oder so etwas leider noch kein
alter es war wirklich eine unfassbare
reise auf die ich euch gleich mitnehmen
werde und bleibt eigentlich nur die
frage zu klären ob das teuerste
restaurant und das beste restaurant der
stadt ist guckt euch an sowie sind also
angekommen und hinter mir ist der
eingang schon wunderschön muss ich sagen
wir sind hier unter den kram häusern in
einem der drei kranhäuser wohnen die
reichen und schönen aus köln und ich
habe mich aber wir gehen jetzt rein und
das ist schon sehr verheißungsvoll aus
hab das ganze ja schon bezahlt das
erwartet fiel
und es geht nicht zurück
hallo er sei doch
wohl
also wirklich das muss man sagen das ist
schon jetzt das schönste restaurant an
dem gewann das einzel reingekommen sind
und schritt für schritt sich so dieser
leuchte rahmen mit dazu gehen ob die
musik an und wir haben wirklich das
große glück besitzen wirklich direkt
neben der kirche dann an den
geschäftsteilen kommen schöner blick
nach draußen riesiger tisch nur für uns
das wirklich verrückt also ich bin und
ich bin kopf mäßig bin ich noch nicht
dabei das ist so krass wieder heute
starten mit dem weißen den meisten
champagner zufolge angst haben
jetzt macht ja so eine flasche
champagner wir sitzen in der tauperiode
unterwegs wird nicht passiert wird mich
bitte was man direkt bemerkt die
schaffen es auf sich uns super gut
anzupassen wir sind jetzt nicht so dass
durchschnitts gehobene klientel von vom
auftreten her sondern
jungs so von dinge und so werden wir
auch angesprochen so wird auch mit uns
geredet dass es feierlich
2016 deutsche lottoblock also das weiße
von meister in einer sciaroni dann
wollen wir mal ganz locker rein starten
mir fehlt für sowas wirklich einfach
dass der mensch bei den teenies auch
alkoholfrei mir fehlt für die palette
bei gehobenen alkoholischen getränke
roten wimpern zu unterscheiden und das
gut was schlecht das hoch lag was
trocken und so was ist so besser aber
das ist schon cool für die mut und
das
muss man erst mal wirken lassen oder
fröhlich muss ich jetzt gar nicht wirken
lassen meine augen sagen er hat nur das
für richtig du guckst du das jetzt an du
erkennst nichts rein gar nicht fassen
bekommen haben ist ein kleiner gruß aus
der küche der alle sechs geschmackssinn
anspricht einzeln wir starten mit diesem
körnchen yuzu limette und eistee
vorstellte kam rein und fest dass mit
mir ein
jacky dass ich davon diese singles an
kopf bekomme beim cockpit zelt von
meinem kopf spitze so weil es so krass
schmeckt gut und das ding ist wir
probieren das zu schmecken die in der
küche wissen was hier rein machen müssen
wie sie zubereiten müssen um diese
reaktion von uns die wir uns nicht
erklären können hervor zuletzt wird
krass schnecke chicorée und kerbel also
das ist wirklich eine sache die man auf
jeden fall tun sollte wenn man im rest
aus wie die es hier geht also wir auch
in experimentellen ansatz haben dass man
sich davon verabschiedet sachen nicht zu
essen also die erste schnecken meines
lebens
rückt oder ob
es jetzt mein favourit so der erste teil
von videos ist jetzt sind wir sehen uns
morgen für k21 wünschen schon im finale
erst dazu bekommen
diese fertigkeit lustigkeit und dann
kommt zu diesem berberitze mit der säure
durchbricht das so ein bisschen ich
täglich füllen jetzt mal in die 3
nachdem wir diese sind roh gegessen hast
was uns heute erwartet ich fühle mich
haben euro doch jetzt schon richtig so
aber auch so mann wurde so bestimmen zu
deinen kopf wird bestimmt darauf dass
wir jetzt so alles schmecken kannst die
haben gerade perfekt jeden einzelnen
geschmack getroffen den wir besitzen den
wir schmecken können und dass dabei
aussehen lassen kunst werden ja das ist
das daher dass auch noch dazu besitzen
dabei
und werden von den kumpels bedienen oder
trinken
mir wird jetzt wieder bewusst das ist zu
komplex für so ein video das man kann
nicht alles überwunden wir probieren das
beste bild ein wenig zur verfügung
stehen derzeit zu zeichnen aber es
bleibt immer was auf der strecke wenn
man sowas über im video wieder gibt es
geht wirklich hier um auch einen
wissenschaftlichen ansatz den man zum
anfang vorgestellt bekommen mit dem man
versteht was man schmecken kann was man
schmeckt und schärft so wirklich ein
bisschen die sinne auf das was möglich
wie habe gerade eben die sechs
geschmackssinn kennengelernt und jetzt
fehlen noch die temperatur komponente
dazu scharf bzw heiß und kalt
beziehungsweise nichts lasst uns
probieren
so viel chili das ist mutig welt
[Musik]
mein gehirn ist warm arbeiten dabei eine
bisherigen eindruck richtig lecker essen
sondern du bewegst einen kurs in
schmecken alles was wir gestern war hier
da da da da nichts war gleich noch
wirklich liebe es bisher so sehr und
dass man hier sitzt und das machen kann
das ist das ultimative privileg so das
ist unglaublich wirklich so ich nehme es
nicht für selbstverständlich muss ich
wirklich einmal so sagen für mich ist es
irgendwie durch ein fahrverbot sitzen
viele meinen job geworden und ich liebe
jedes bisschen davon also wirklich danke
nochmal an der stelle eine sache möchte
ich am relativen anfangen von diesem
video nochmal aus der welt habe ich bin
mir sicher es werden wieder kommentare
kommen so was bringt mir das wenn ich
dann auch mal einen döner essen musst du
musst danach keinen döner essen gehen du
wirst davon satt weil genau so wie du
schneller sagt wirst wenn du langsamer
ist wirst du wenn du über vier stunden
verteilt kleine portion ist und am ende
bist du auch nicht falls es einfach nur
happy
wir sind hier wirklich im geschmacks
disneyland habe ich das gefühl er kam
dazu und hat uns diesen teller hier
gemacht man kann sich wahrscheinlich
nichts darunter vorstellen das hat auch
in ganz bestimmten grund was wir gerade
gelernt haben die sechs
geschmacksrichtungen sind hier noch mal
aufgeführt süß sauer bitter salzig und
alle sechs finden sich in jedem gang
wieder den wir bekommen in jedem als
kleines spiel rät man immer was zu was
gehört also man hat quasi wirklich von
jamie fiction aspekt quasi beim essen
und wenn man es nicht schmeckt kann man
einfach auf diesem blog der hier die
ganze zeit schon am tisch steht drauf
legen und weiß zum beispiel johannes mit
zitrone steht für sie außer blätter
kaffee steht für bitter das ist auch
alles hier noch mal erklärt in so einem
kleinen beilage heft zitrone heißt sarah
wog ado heißt fed ihr versteht und so
hat man nicht nur ein geschmackserlebnis
sondern auch noch ein kleines ratespiel
nebenbei wir wussten zu diesem zeitpunkt
zwar noch nicht wie viele gänge und zu
erwarten werden aber wir wussten das
passt nicht in ein video sie hätten
daraus auch fünf videos machen können
aber wir wollten viel lieber nur die
highlights zeigen und genau das werden
wir jetzt tun die verrücktesten zutaten
die ausgefallensten gänge und unsere
reaktion viel spaß jetzt geben
entwicklung hat auch aufmerksam machen
und dass wir noch keinen steck haben das
fingerfood die haben wirklich eier das
finde ich merk so wirklich
lass dir schmecken weißt du was sie
faszinierend finde ist dass nur und es
schmeckt super gut aber dann liest du
was da drin ist hast du daraus bestimmt
das sind bananen und rausgeschnitten es
schmeckt für sich genommen unfassbar gut
und ist wahnsinnig edel und unglaublich
gut gemacht aber dann beim zweiten
wissen zu gucken was drin ist dazu
schmecken was drin ist macht einfach
spaß
kurzgefasst hühnerei schwarz lackiert
innen drin nordseekrabben lauch um auf
gebrannter lauf 200 grad zwei stunden
ich liebe die präsentation du kriegst
das hingestellt und du musst das erklärt
bekommen
[Musik]
sowas liebe ich war fast das leck so das
ding franz getrocknete grabbeltisch das
ist unfassbar vollmundig
carabinieri
kanäle die ihre kündigung
wo ihr das hier ist ein herz einer palme
alter was haben wir da
wo ich will
die natur so vorkommt und
champagner kommt durch man muss gar
nicht mehr sagen dass das was auf den
punkt ist sich aber sicher alles was wir
essen ist perfekt weißt du was ich mal
welpe mal dass du eins davon so
nachkochen muss für mich und dann will
ich dich filmen und sehen wie du dabei
verkauft obwohl du das rezept vor dir
hast
diese präzision die in der küche an den
tag gelegt wird im verbund mit der
geschwindigkeit die an den tag gelegt
wird so einfach pure professionalität so
ist wird kaum geredet jeder gibt wortlos
dem anderer ist es fast telepathie darin
nummer fünf grüne mandl ziegen rekord
automatisch dafür wäre gemüse vorteil
basilikum aufzüge wohnungs grad erklärt
klingt krass aber regional das ganze
tier wird verwertet
[Musik]
ich liebe es dass darunter die
überraschung ist bis es wieder game
action at its best gespannt ob das ich
bin ich gespannt
also durch dieser reucher geruch ist
oder hass dieser geräucherte geschmack
der an die gelb-schwarzen credo kommt
ist unvorstellbar
das war ich gerade nicht unprofessionell
oder unfreundlich sondern das ist die
art in kölner brauhäuser immer so oder
wirst nur beleidigt gefühlt freut sich
der erste und einzige haben der mit der
pinzette angerichtet ist
der gau oder eine creme
es ist jetzt wirklich nur noch für ein
spaß mein bauch ist aufs doppelte
gewachsen jetzt schon und es geht weiter
da kommt glaube ich so
taube ist mir ein bisschen zu wenig
treffen entweder vorher ganzen trüffel
drauf gegeben
ich muss jetzt glaubt eröffnen
was das ist so viel wie
willst du das alles bewerten frage ich
frage dann muss er wirklich eine
hausarbeit darüber schreiben ich könnte
jetzt startest du
dich nicht ist er auch ja
haben uns ja bekannt vorher hatte zuerst
natürlich und dann abkühlen ich frage
mich die ganze zeit wird immer noch
wörter dafür finden kannst ich bin seit
dem 23 irgendwie so wortlos ich hoffe
glücklich jetzt alles einfach ich kann
es gar nicht beschreiben
ich könnte auch wenn die kamera nicht
laufen will ich könnte auch stimmen
welche es macht mir so viel spaß auch
das so zu reflektieren und auszusprechen
aber man könnte man könnte dieses
restaurant ohne probleme ganz allein
besuchen ja
ich bin jetzt mittlerweile steht doch in
so einer art trauen wir so hin und her
bin nur noch so brav am rhein ab
so funktioniert es nur noch als mensch
der genießt
das eis
diese rauchige holz note im ice zusammen
erlebt ja was ist dein lieblings eis der
rauchige holz eis es ist nicht
vergleichbar
in creme zu niedrig
wir sind im finale
[Musik]
ich vermag es nicht zu sagen aber es ist
einfach ein traum und da ist so viel
illusionen dabei die morsche ist keine
branche haben wir schon gefragt gerade
so das ist ein schock und das muss ein
teig
wahnsinn das ist nicht
durch diese schüssel mit blubbernden
brauchen dann hast du wirklich die
illusion von wald atmosphäre zu genießen
die nächste geschmack sind jetzt auch
eine süße form in form von ihnen habe
ich auf der karte die einzelnen
sind und wenn ihr wissen wollt
mit ihrem rad drehen
[Musik]
richard
ich habe hier die rechnung von unserem
restaurant besuch und es schmerzt wenn
ich darauf schaue
708 euro dazu habe ich noch mal 50 euro
trinkgeld gegeben mit anderen worten das
teuerste restaurant in der stadt und
mein teuerster restaurantbesuch elfer
und auf lange zeit würde ich mal denken
es war trotzdem eine unglaubliche reise
und ich muss das ganze in schriftform
irgendwie verpacken weil ich kann das
nicht so raus quatschen aber deshalb
seht ihr jetzt meine bewertung und dann
sehen wir mal kurz wie ordnet sich ein
restaurant dieser klasse in die
restlichen restaurants dieser stadt ein
gar nicht das wird ab dem ersten moment
in dem man das opfer und klebe tritt
klar in dieser welt des absoluten luxus
ist man anders man ist um zu entdecken
experience days heißt das konzept und
genau das ist programm als
durchschnittlich versierter gaumen wird
man zahllose neue
geschmackskombinationen und zutaten
kennen lernen welche kunstvoll
eingesetzt werden die atmosphäre ist
nicht zuletzt dank des tollen service so
exzellent man sollte jedoch nicht nach
einfachen genuss suchen sondern mit
freude am entdecken erscheint dann kann
sich auch der hohe preis lohnt für mich
4,5 von 5 punkten es war auf jeden fall
eine kranke erfahrung danke dass sie
teil davon war danke dass ihr das
möglich macht und wir sehen uns beim
nächsten video das hoffentlich ein
bisschen günstiger wird wieder
[Musik]